et c'est un vieux pays la France d'un
vieux continent comme le mien l'Europe
qui vous le dit aujourd'hui aucun
d'entre nous n'éprouve la moindre
complaisance à l'égard de Saddam Hussein
et du régime irakien un usage de la
force serait si lourd de conséquence
pour les hommes pour la région et pour
la stabilité internationale qui ne
saurait être envisagé qu'en dernière
extrémité il y a une alternative à la
guerre
des armées l'Irak par les inspections
l'option de la guerre peut apparaître a
priori la plus rapide mais n'oublions
pas qu'après avoir gagné la guerre il
faut construire la paix dans ce temple
des Nations Unies nous sommes les
gardiens d'un idéal nous sommes les
gardiens d'une conscience la lourde
responsabilité et l'immense honneur qui
sont les nôtres doivent nous conduire à
donner la priorité au désarmement dans
la paix